جديد في اخر تطورات الحرب على الارض
باوكرانيا اشتدت حده المعارك في محيط
مدينه باكموت الاستراتيجيه في اقليم دومبس
وقال مؤسس ميليشيا الروسيه
انه تمت السيطره على بلده برسكا بيافكا
الواقعه الشمال مدينه
واضافها انه على الرغم من قطع امدادات
الذخائر والخسائر الفادحه فنقوته تمكنت من
السيطره بشكل كامل على البلده
في المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
نقواتها قتلت سبعه جنود روس على الاقل
واستحوذت على معدات واسعه في جبهه بخمه
الشرقيه اوكرانيا ونشرت وزاره الدفاع صورا
قالت انها لعمليه استهدفت القوات الروسيه
اثناء محاولتها تسلل الى مواقع اوكرانيه
على جبهه بخموتا
وعلى صعيدي الدعم العسكري الغربي
لاوكرانيا اكد حلفائه كييف في اوروبا
والنيتو على ضروره تعزيز الدعم العسكري
المقدمه لها لتحقيق الانتصار وعلنت
بريطانيا والمانيا ان تعهدات الاخيره
بتزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات ستحول مسار
الحرب مع التاكيد على ضروره تفكير الحلفاء
في تعزيز دفاعات اوكرانيا على المدى
البعيد
[موسيقى]